[Music]
I'm in downtown Los Angeles at e3 this
is the Electronic Entertainment Expo and
they're unveiling the future of video
games a struggling industry apparently
kids these days are more interested in
reading and walking in the woods but in
playing video games this is something
they don't tell you do you think it's
gonna be all guys there's gorgeous women
everywhere it's blowing my mind I'm very
much in love with you
this is the Sarah Palin of the future
those pumps are so sexy look at those
boots those boots were designed by Wayne
LaPierre the head of the NRA there's an
exciting showdown this week at the
convention both Xbox and Playstation are
unveiling brand-new consoles the big
question in the gaming industry is which
is the better console and what does a
naked woman look like here representing
PlayStation is Arum is that correct
a ROM actually Iran I keep getting that
rice all right I'm Conan tell us is this
oh this is a console right here do you
play the game if it's encased in a Cuba
lucite let me chew the stats really
quickly tell me what are we looking at
here how many REMS how many gigs you
know what portals can be accessed using
various graphite interfaces go the
system is very easy to develop on x86
architecture the eight gigabytes of
gddr5 the fastest memory on the market
and it's a unified pool of memory our
game makers can use it in
[Applause]
this just looks like a strange dream
that I had after a lot of Mexican food
and some anesthesia I think oh we have
not met what is her name sir Ricky Ricky
and what do you do Ricky I'm one of the
people made this game you made this game
now how high do you need to be to play
the game you mind if I try tell me what
to do
these guys are finding these seeds okay
I make actions the seed turned into a
kite and then they find those parts do
you have a diagnosis have you been
diagnosed
[Music]
I will tell you this I've been on this
planet awhile I've never been this
contented I spent six weeks with the
Dalai Lama in deep meditation and I
didn't feel this good okay wrong I don't
know much but in the short time I've
been here I'm convinced that the new ps4
PlayStation console is the greatest
console in the history of gaming and
there's none other your endorsement
would mean it's priceless actually isn't
priceless I'm looking for $600,000 this
is Larry and you're representing Xbox
one absolutely sell me on this I don't
know what to do
PlayStation 4 Xbox one no we got the
sensor our Kinect sensor you can
actually see your heartbeat that's right
you can see where your the Bloods going
in your body I mean it's unbelievable
I'll tell you what the Bloods going on
my body there's also in the triggers
itself there's a little thing called a
haptic feedback it's gonna be perhaps a
little gentler when you're shooting
[Applause]
somebody's talking to you and thank you
listen I tend to blow with the wind but
you're the last person I talked to
and I now believe Xbox is the best I
appreciate expert on Xbox one
I think Xbox one is the best system only
because I talked to you second ok this
is PJ and PJ the game that you're gonna
demonstrate for me is called Ryse son of
Rome ok and how long have you been
working on this game me for about two
years
alright I have bad news for you you
misspelled rise and the barbarians have
taken over the harbour you know what the
greatest danger he's facing here that's
sitting water-- probably a lot of
bacteria no he just put that sword
through the back of his neck what's
wrong with you people when you design
these things what's wrong with you
please try to keep it real keep it real
oh yeah does that happen in your
childhood this is Josh bridge the that's
not necessary the executive producer of
the Xbox one game Dead Rising 3 I'm
guessing it's a zombie game absolutely
filled with them how long you've been
working on this game for a number of
years actually labor of love just
getting in there massaging the zombies
and every nook and cranny ok you're
creeped and is he carrying what is he
carrying in that pouch on the side is
that for his a little welding torch oh I
thought that was for making s'mores
what's he looking to do just kind of
find a way out of this area ok Oh either
that's blood well they all had a lot of
gazpacho an hour ago
he's low on health so he's just gonna
get some food and I'm saying yeah that
hot dogs probably fresh she'll [ __ ] them
yeah it's only been there at nine months
you don't be a funny wrinkle on this
game if each zombie had a lawyer do that
mainly just every time you killed a
zombie that you had to go through tons
of paperwork okay I've just had like two
solid hours of killing gore and death
I want a little joy in my life so we're
here at Nintendo Wii where mushrooms
raised small Italian man in a magical
world no one dies oh I'm really steering
yep and I'm a little dinosaur maybe
dinosaurs ooh Oh finished I beat you
I've got a winner
I've got a win I've never wanted
anything more than I want this right now
i won
Octopussy here is it Xbox one is a
PlayStation 4
it is this mario kart game it's the one
game I can play the one game tragic are
you doing the voice
23 years are you married no I'm single I
just trying to rescue the princess so I
can finally marry her once and for all
so when you're dating at some point the
voice is a draw and then you pit a point
where the voice is like you got to knock
it off with the voice they say right
says you make my HUD go but the beat but
the boom bah bah bah right and then she
says please stop it you're killing our
relationship and you say
you've got to stop this it's a sickness
it's a perk you realize you're ill this
is a recurring dream I have there's a a
Geisha what are there carrot I don't I
don't care I don't care if their
characters are okay I swear to God I
forget why I came here in the first
place something about video games or
something III hot girls come here for
the girls
[Applause]